all right that's it let's enjoy can you
do it I just hungry
hi I'm Michele I'm Brendan and today
we're gonna try and guess which one of
these burgers is the cheapest
which ones mid-range and which ones
expensive yeah I definitely eat so many
burgers okay so first impressions what
do you think they all look good I think
I this is reminding me that I don't
think there is such a thing as a bad
burger I'm gonna know this for sure
without a doubt look at that thick look
so good on patty on Patty's beef because
what we're made of but look at like this
bacon versus that big hey this is where
we're gonna we're gonna diverge a little
bit that's a pretty good burger stack oh
yeah look at her she's thick that's 2
C's right there
bacon is mean it should actually have
texture like me that making looks legit
are you pure meaty goodness yeah like oh
my god I stick with this one being the
most expensive this one might be
mid-range I'm gonna change mid-range
okay one of those two mid-range on this
one I do feel like I feel like this is
gonna be the material I'm still
confident in my assessment how about you
yeah I would say this is still like the
mid-tier burger yeah
ten percent
so this one was my most expensive one
right original yeah you think this one's
most expensive I still think is the most
expensive I'm gonna stick with that okay
this one I'm guessing mid-range on this
guy
mid-range yeah it does have a nice
bottom that's what it is that's what's
kind of what I'm going for I'm going on
the bun so this is the brioche one so we
think this one is expensive we agree on
that
yes but a lot of that is bun base we
haven't we can't attest to the quality
of the meat once you get into it it's a
thick could be thick one I might be
wrong the bun is when you bite into this
you can taste a little bit of sauce the
like texture of the burger and softness
of the bun I feel like because this is
kind of like a balanced hold this is
probably the more expensive burger Oh
angry this is probably better food
what is it more delicious then they can
eat it sorry not sorry
sometimes cheap burgers are the best
exactly yeah right so I'm still gonna go
with most expensive on this one
I still save that range I still think
this is the most expensive one Sam
I'm becoming more and more paranoid that
this frumpy guy is gonna be like an $24
burger or something I feel like where
this is like a relative situation
at the last content last one this is the
wild card I okay first of all I love the
look in this picture that you know I
don't want that piece so I'm not sure
like that this phenomena looks all
deflated and smoosh the rest of the bear
has some work to do
visually alright so now we have the
soggy and wrinkled but experienced
burger the grandma burger the grandma
burger I wish I didn't call it that you
can see all the layers combined it's
like lettuce tomato cheese bacon me
right and it's like you got like a
little medium rare except been going so
maybe I could be wrong this one cooker
that right you know what it sounds like
kind of interesting because this is like
an eggy bus and Shake Shack II yeah now
I'm like questioning my whole world
I think the Shake Shack I have the
cheese is so cute how's the bacon bacon
bacon cetera
there should be meeting of texture to
some that describe oh I guess I like my
bacon slugging I like mine kind of
crispy but mine was like just gently
cupping your face it was like a soft
pillow in your mouth like yeah I don't
need that but you know solid juicy like
it has all the elements you would want
in a burger
mmm I'm deadly I think I've changed my
mind
I think we're most expensive same yeah
I'm gonna stick I'm I stick with my guns
here I think it's the best and the
cheapest
and now that we're done we know this is
a bacon in different Wendy's we don't
how much it cost how much is a bacon a
different windows Oh I said any numbers
mid-range burger because of the extra
patties I knew it
mind games the important thing here is
that you were wrong about this one no
the important thing here is that we got
to eat a bunch of burgers 1a 1b cheapest
burger ah see that's what I thought
it's the bun ah it is the bun high-five
we did it so what's your line and then
that's the cheapest swear this is the
cheapest we did say the cheaper burgers
are the better burgers oh my goodness
I know now you're like I'm so confident
in all of my choices I never waivered
I was worried for a second I bet you
could take the button from this one and
put it on that burger in charge 20 bucks
oh yeah and I'll pay for it don't come
at me with beef knowledge because I've
got this one wrong I think this
highlights the best thing about burgers
is that they don't have to be expensive
to be great my favorite was the cheapest
one it's delicious it's so hard to mess
up a burger that well there is you can't
find cool value and like great
experiences with like fancy burgers I'm
sure fancy burgers are great but if you
need a burger you can get a delicious
one if every reasonable price it's why
it's God's perfect
[Music]